all right guys bang bang Darius is back
Darius Bitcoin thirty thousand dollars
now two times off the bottom 100
appreciation since the bottom what
exactly is going on how are you
evaluating what's going on with Bitcoin
yeah no great question man I think it's
uh so hat tip to anyone who made it
specifically looking at my boy here over
here rocking the New York Hat I have to
join you
um but you know there's a couple things
going on in in this market and I think
all of which are appropriate for where
we are in this particular phase and so
we'll start with the market pricing in
of the FED pause pivot historically
speaking you know when you would go back
and we sequence you know we've done a
big study on bear markets and you know
through the lens of the s p whether it
be through the lens of the inflation
cycle the growth cycle but most
importantly the liquidity cycle and what
we found is that a couple of things
markets tend to bottom right around when
the fed and flexes liquidity cycle
either with rate Cuts or pausing or
Panic rate Cuts Etc or doing QE
obviously in the most in the post crisis
Sarah but another thing that we've
learned in that study is that
historically speaking pause pivots tend
to be the most bullish pivots and the
reason I think that is the case again
that is you know speaking to me is I
believe the market when the FED pauses
looks for board and reflates soft
Landing expectations they go the coast
is clear things are fine you know the
FED didn't break anything it did not
over tighten us into a Draconian
economic scenario therefore investors
feel a lot more comfortable taking risks
so I think that's part of what's going
on here is the market is clearly
sniffing out the FED eventually getting
to this pause pivot we happen to think
it's probably more likely to be the June
meeting but best neither here nor there
it's obviously April markets are
forward-looking the second thing I think
is happening in the cryptocurrency
market and this is broadly broader
markets in general is the inflection in
the Chinese both growth cycle and the
Chinese liquidity cycle and this is
something that's had a pretty
significant influence on on global you
know sort of assets you know really
since October you know we've seen
Chinese growth bottom and really start
to re-accelerate particularly coming out
of their uh the end of their zero covet
policy and then more importantly we're
starting to see we're not starting to
see we have seen a pretty significant uh
acceleration in the size and growth of
the pboc's balance sheet it's grown by
roughly about you know 1.5 trillion Yuan
which is somewhere around let's call it
350 370 a billion US dollars in the last
three months so that's very clearly been
very positive in terms of supporting
assets that the Chinese themselves like
to speculate in namely Bitcoin so I
think those confluencing factors are
really contributing to what you're
seeing in your screens here what's
fascinating to me is this idea of global
liquidity so a lot of people have been
focused on the U.S central bank balance
sheet and obviously looking at uh you
know it's going down it's going down
we're losing you know hundreds of
billions of dollars off of that balance
sheet quantitative tightening is
happening oh are they going to Pivot and
we saw with the banking crisis there was
some liquidity added bad is that QE is
it not but actually since really the
start of the year we have seen a net
growth of global liquidity mainly
because as you point out there's a ton
of inflows happening in Asian countries
and so when we go ahead and we see that
occurring is that something that it's a
simple look at the top 10 or top 20
Global central banks and simply say if
it's net positive asset prices go up if
it's net negative and there's tightening
going on on a global basis asset prices
are going down like can we just boil it
down to that simple equation
yeah that is actually true I've done a
tremendous amount of work on this and
the correlations are very tight they
continue to be very tight this is across
digital assets this is called stratify
assets both stocks and bonds you can
very clearly see that tight correlation
particularly on a levels basis in what
we you know if you sort of aggregate
what we would we do here at 42 macro is
we aggregate the top five central banks
once you get beyond the top five you
know there's really you're hardly
talking about any share
um so when you aggregate their their
total balance sheet their size and U.S
dollar terms what you see is global
Equity market cap is very correlated to
that Global fixed income market cap is
very correlated to that and obviously in
the post-crisis era uh digital asset
market cap is all very clear related to
that so I don't think it's as simple as
aggregating it because again by the time
you aggregate it you know it's a
coincident indicator it's our job as
investors to you know anticipate
inflections and and Trends in the
indicator as opposed to just
acknowledging that it's gone up or gone
down because by then it's obviously
again too late to do anything about it
in asset terms it it's our view you know
for a variety of reasons that we're sort
of getting I wouldn't say to the end of
the global liquidity cycle in terms of
the inflection that we've seen but we're
certainly starting to see Peter out and
stall out and it's our view that by the
time we get into the second half of the
year a lot of the positive dynamics that
we've seen out of the bank of Japan
balance sheet and some of the positive
dynamics that we've seen out of the pboc
balance sheet are likely to start to
dissipate which would ultimately give
way to what we think is still ongoing
which is the balance sheet contraction
here in the Federal in the U.S the
vis-a-vis the Federal Reserve so when we
see this playing out one of the pieces
that I keep coming back to is the United
States Federal Reserve they went ahead
and they jacked interest rates from zero
to five percent and they dropped a
couple hundred billion dollars off of
their balance sheet we never got the
official inflation number below six
percent when they did all of that
at the same time in 2023 we have seen
inflation month over month actually
accelerating in what seems to be a
little bit of a scary situation and so
if we are now talking about pausing of
interest rate hikes and inflation has
not come back down to two percent should
we just buckle up and expect you know
eight ten twelve percent inflation or is
there some other Dynamic at play that
will keep inflation down even if they
return back to some level of a loose
monetary policy uh that's a phenomenal
question one of the best questions I've
gotten all year because I think the
underlying question within the question
is is this a Federal Reserve that is
serious about it's a priceability
mandate because I think that's the if
you if you have a depending on what your
answer is to that question that really
dictates what you're doing here in
financial markets we happen to believe
that they are serious about their price
stability management there's a couple of
reasons why one is very clearly that so
many people in the United States of
America live paycheck to paycheck and so
it's very clear from our perspective
that under a democratic regime
Democratic Administration you know you
have the left you know kind of pushing
and leaning on the FED it has Warren
being a prime example of that we do
believe that the FED is sort of more
focused would be more focused on on
achieving inflation outcomes than it
would be otherwise but that's I think
that's less of an issue I think the
bigger issue is with respect to the FED
policy and its desire to to get the
inflation Genie back in the bottle I
think it has a lot more to do with you
know the financing in the treasury
market you know if you go and you look
at you know kind of you know you can
close the treasury market you know us us
private sector participants we now own
just shy of 40 percent of the treasury
market that's up from like 30 percent in
in recent quarters and you know part of
the reason for that obviously we've seen
foreign central banks you know uh uh
divest their treasury Holdings we've
obviously seen the FED divest this
treasury Holdings uh vis-a-vqe and
obviously you know commercial Banks you
know are looking around and divesting
their treasury Holdings as well
Signature Bank Silicon Valley Bank being
you know two
um you two banks that have gone by the
wayside because they didn't do it fast
enough you know this is a real big issue
we're losing a lot of the sort of core
components of the treasury demand curve
and the more we push the you know sort
of the incremental kind of Supply upon
the private sector thought a lot more
the greater the probability is that we
have higher and higher interest rates
that we we need to use to capitalize the
US government and I think first and
foremost one the FED doesn't want that
to happen to begin with because it's
part of their mandate if people think
the FED as a dual mandate it doesn't
have a dual man it has three mandates
price stability maximum employment and
moderate long-term interest rates and
the moderate long-term interest rate
piece comes into play when you think
about
if you don't put the inflation Genie
back in the bottle going back to your
question where are our long-term
interest rate supposed to be over the
long term I happen to think the Bond
Market thinks the FED is going to put
the placing Genie back in the bottle
that's why we still see interest rates
with a three handle on the 10-year et
cetera but ultimately If the Fed if the
bottom Market is wrong on that
expectation then we need a significant
repricing higher across the entire
interest rate curve to account for that
ultimately that's going to be extremely
bullish for asset markets right you're
talking about a fed that's just going to
be perpetually easy but I think the
process of going from point A to point B
could be a little bit of a little bit
challenging so I always like to dumb
things down for myself to make sure that
I understand and one of the you know
kind of ideas that I have or Frameworks
is you know when you're in high school
and every weekend there's a party and
you go to the party and they're like you
know B plus a minus parties and you go
every week and you see the same friends
you guys have a good time but then every
once in a while like maybe once a year
there's an absolute Banger like there's
just a party that you will talk about
for 30 years and it usually because
there's a bigger crowd it's crazier it's
more fun there's more alcohol obviously
no one drinks in high school it's just
this awesome thing right and when you
think about that party you basically
spend the next couple of years trying to
recreate the magic of like that one
night right if you think of financial
markets 2020 and 2021 We're The Banger
emergency interest rate cuts to zero
quantitative easing like the world had
never seen before and asset prices
skyrocketed to the Moon it was awesome
we were all drunk and we had a blast I
think that an entire generation of
investors are going to be begging for a
recreation of that time period will we
see zero percent interest rates and
trillions of dollars of quantitative
easing again in the next three five ten
years like how do you think about the
potential to recreate that type of
environment versus like no maybe we'll
just being a more moderate kind of
normal interest rate normal loose
monetary policy type of environment
that's a phenomenal question again uh
that's all I do that's all I do here
that's all you do is ask it all the
questions man I appreciate you bro
um so it actually the answer is yes but
not to the same degree uh I do believe
we're headed for what we call you know
recession what most people call
recession what we call a phase two
credit cycle downturn same same thing
and in that process the FED is going to
likely you know be you know concerned
about you know ultimately the level of
unemployment
Etc and we'll ultimately have to respond
to asset markets telling it to do those
things now are we going to cut from five
back to zero are we going to do you know
let's call it go back to 120 billion
dollars a month of QE I don't think so I
think I think what we saw on Cove it was
a pretty unique and extraordinary
circumstance that in my opinion going
back to this kind of chasing the The
Banger of the party uh analogy I think
it sort of Trapped a lot of investors in
a regime that thinks monetary policy the
FED reaction function and the reaction
function of you know policy makers
globally is going to easier and easier
and easier we happen to think the
opposite is true it's actually at every
subsequent Market cycle and business
cycle it's probably going to be slightly
less easy than it was in the previous
cycle and I think this is going to be a
classic example of that and part of the
reason for that is the underlying
structural Trend in inflation is
transposing itself higher you know if we
uh we have a pretty sophisticated
Dynamic Factor model that we built that
is specifically designed to project a
longer run trend of inflation not just
inflation is doing on the next six month
next 12 month basis but the underlying
trend of the time series and that model
suggesting that the underlying Trend in
the time Series has practically doubled
almost doubled from where it was
trending at per prior to covet and so
that doesn't really sound like a lot but
not only is that doubling process a lot
in Delta terms but it's also we are now
talking about an underlying trend of
core PC inflation you know underlying
you know measures of underlying
inflation like trim means PCH median PC
you know these are these are kind of
your more wonky measures of inflation
we're talking about levels that are
going closer to three as opposed to
below two and when you have a lot and
don't forget let's not just remember the
fed's uh inflation Target is two percent
and I think it's going to be two percent
for quite a while until we get that
employment rate high enough for them to
have political cover to take it higher
than two but until we get to that point
it's very likely that this is a Federal
Reserve that has to sort of I don't want
to say sit on its hands but it's
certainly going to be a lot more gun shy
relative to the peg part the kegger that
we just described you know this this
Banger of a party
um you know because again inflation is a
congressionally mandated mandate you
know as long as the treasury Market's
not malfunctioning you know as long as
the jobs Market is reasonably robust
they have to turn their attention to
this congressionally mandated mandate
and it's unfortunate because we all know
how this party ends right it's going to
end with the cops coming or all you know
climbing over the fence and running in
the alleyway we've been there
it's funny you say that because that's
exactly what my next question was going
to be is it feels like thinking crisis
where we saw the second and third
largest bank failures in U.S history was
kind of like when the cops show up and
everyone's like oh and they just
run to someone else's house and they try
to get away right
we have so many great memories right now
this is so good I never did any of this
by the way this is all hypothetical I
read about it in books and watched some
YouTube videos but is that kind of
what's going on is like hey we had the
party and then the cops are showing up
and that's why there's bank failures and
pain and people are trying to figure out
how the hell we're going to get through
this without more things breaking
you know I I wouldn't say it's the cops
yet because I think the cops is the
actual business cycle the cops are the
hey look you did too much not only did
you just cause a couple banks to go bust
you actually causing a broader credit
punch in the U.S economy which I think
is already underway we can already see
it in the cni or in the in the small
business um you know lending data uh
that we get on a weekly basis in the h8
survey uh but going back to to the
analogy I think what Signature Bank and
and and Silicon Valley Bank and and you
know the the other bank that went with
us
it's what happens you go bus people
forget you
um so what I think is the more
appropriate analogy for this moment in
time is the nosy neighbor
the nosy neighbor is knocking on the
door say hey can you turn the music down
or I'm going to call the cops and you
know so you turn the music down you put
everybody inside you pull the kegs
inside and you know everyone's partying
inside but eventually you know just too
many people in there to keep the keep
the party um keep the party going
unnoticed for an extended period of time
So eventually that nosy neighbor will
call the cops and ultimately that
calling the cops process in our view is
the recession that in our opinion has
yet to be pressed in so what are you
paying attention to moving forward Are
there specific metrics or data points
that you're looking for that will tell
you all's clear or you know brace for
more kind of pain ahead what is
specifically are you looking at
yeah great question so no no there's
never going to be an all clear signal in
my opinion financial markets never say
hey sell here buy here that's just not
how the the process works right you have
to fight through a lot of confirmation
bias whenever you're making these
inflection type calls uh at the lows or
at the highs and in financial markets
and we certainly have some some great
experience doing that I think what you
need to do is have a more robust process
to understand hey look there are some
cycles that you know you know go back
hundreds and hundreds of years of you
know Market history that need to get
priced in we're talking about the
employment cycle we're talking about the
growth cycle the inflation cycle has yet
to come come fully um you know fully uh
get to where it needs to go and
ultimately the liquidity cycle in our
opinion has yet to meaningfully inflect
so you know there's some you know with
respect to I think the liquidity cycle
is probably the most important one going
back to that study we did on bear
markets that suggests that markets tend
to bottom right around that inflection
liquidity cycle and the FED in liquidity
cycle because again dollar liquidity is
the more important most important uh
feature of that blog Global liquidity
system you know when we're looking at
you know the dollar liquidity cycle I
think what's most I think what's
happening right now that I think a lot
of not enough investors are paying
attention to is the destruction of
private sector liquidity we have M1
growth Contracting at one of the fastest
rates that's ever contracted M1 is
narrow money growth this is in the
monetary base plus all the checkable
deposits in the banking sector and that
money is effectively leaving the banking
sector and chasing money market fund
exposure of which 83 percent is is is
you know sort of Treasury government
style money market fund exposure and as
a function of not having enough t-bill
Supply a lot of that money is winding up
in itself in the Super Bowl facility so
I don't see a real reason for that to
stop until the FED Cuts interest rates
you know we're talking about a 100
percentile spread between what money
Mark government money market funds are
are paying investors at around you know
it's called four and a half percent
versus the 49 basis points that banks
are paying on average across the country
and so that hundred percent I'll spread
in our opinion was just the Silicon
Valley Bank Signature Bank that was the
wake-up call for investors to realize
hey look I press a few buttons and get
you know a decent amount of money on my
on my cash and I think a lot of
investors it's very clear in the data
that a lot of investors are doing that
and more importantly it's very clear in
the data that this is causing you know
small Bank small Regional Banks and I
say small with air quotes because the
FED defines small Banks as any Bank
outside the top 25 in total assets well
these things are meaningful shares of
the economy they're about 40 percent of
all loans and leases they're about 30
percent of a total bank deposit so we
have a serious problems in small Banks
it's going to be a serious problem for
the large U.S economy and so I'm
watching the destruction of private
sector money and seeing how that is not
you is or is not being offset by the
reflation of public sector everybody
it's clearly not being offset by public
sector money reflation here in the U.S
but it has been offset by public sector
money reflation in China and Japan so
what I'm I'm most intently focused on is
when that sort of crosses you know when
we still have this public sector money
our private sector money deflation here
in America that again is not being
committedly offset by any Central Bank
in the world that's when I think we're
going to start to run into problems and
asset Market terms again and I think
that's probably sometime in Q3 maybe
early
as we continue to watch this play out uh
Jerome Powell is going to have some
tough decisions to make here
um are investors just watching him or do
you think that investors will start
trying to front run what they believe he
will do do you see there being some
other strategy for investors it seems
like a lot of people are sitting in cash
or treasuries they're trying to kind of
figure out what to do uh real estate
there's almost like no deals happening
right we've seen massive drop off
because the cost of capital has spiked
so significantly we've seen a lot of
stocks fall many of them have not yet
recovered Bitcoin seems to be one of the
unique ones where it fell and it's
recovered pretty significantly but it's
still down you know 50 or so from its
all-time high what are investors going
to do what do you think they should be
doing in this type of scenario
Yeah in our view because again we have
the view that there's going to come in
time where that private sector money
deflation is not being offset by the
public sector money refund it will
eventually but I think there's going to
be a window of time that could be
multiple quarters where that is not
being that is not the case for that
public sector money reflation is not
offsetting the private sector money
deflation this is happening globally by
the way if you look at narrow money
growth globally on a world PPP weighted
basis it's actually declining for the
first time ever the time series only on
a year over year basis and so we have
considerable private sector money
deflation on us right now it's just
being offset for now so in terms of what
I think markets are doing I think
they're front running the fit the
Market's always trying to front run and
game the FED right you know if you look
at the the bond market particularly the
the shorter end of the bond market the
money market curves you know their
pricing in some pretty significant rate
Cuts over the next 12 to 18 months in
fact if you look at the euro dollar
curve we're talking about three full
rate cuts by the end of the year so
that's a pretty significant move and I
think that pricing in markets is
effectively allowing investors to sort
of of bootrest risk Assets in the
context of not seeing more private
sector money deflation that might be the
theme of this interview right you know
in the context of markets being able to
say well we know the fed's about to be
easy so I can speculate that's totally
fine and I think that's a very
appropriate thing to do at this phase of
the market cycle I think as you roll the
clock forward and maybe one perhaps two
quarters I think the the actual private
sector amount of deflation will be too
great for investors to speculate with
you're going to actually need that
offsetting um private public public
sector money reflation and so I think
the most appropriate thing to do as an
investor from my perspective is to be
reducing your risk at certain price
levels you know we actually had a 30k
price Target on bitcoin a few weeks ago
said Hey look it's probably going to go
to 30k I think I would be selling it at
30k obviously this is not the program to
tell people without Bitcoin but you know
that's our you know that's our our view
for you know institutional investors
folks who are actually you know trying
to uh risk manage the Capital Market
cycle broadly speaking equities I think
I think equities have a lot more
downside in Delta adjust terms and
volatility just to terms than Bitcoin
because I think Bitcoin is is actually
undergoing what could potentially be a
regime change
um you know it's actually becoming the
digital goal that it was marketed as for
a long period of time but technically
wasn't it was really just a high beta
speculative risk Ascot and it's now
actually pulling forward some of these
digital transitive properties and so
ultimately I think that probably will
insulate its downside again on a
volatility adjusted basis more of it to
hybrid assets so it's going to go down
more if the s p goes down a lot but
again I don't think you need to be
overly concerned about Bitcoin retesting
its lows in a way that I do think you
need to be concerned about the stock
market retesting its lows because again
stock market is not only these liquidity
Dynamics and these growth dynamics that
they contend with it also possible as
earnings and we're about to go on to
potentially be a very deep earnings
recession at the bare minimum I think
we're going to get a pretty deep
earnings recession and not only will it
be deep in Delta terms it's also going
to be deep in expectations terms you
look if you pull up Bloomberg consensus
earnings estimates they're talking about
earnings going to be growing 10 thank
you for year over year they could be
down 30.
seriously I mean our model suggests that
recession is likely to commence in the
fourth quarter of this year so they mean
they could easily be down 30. so I mean
in our opinion I think the stock market
is probably the most dangerous asset
class here you know done to my head I'd
rather be long Bitcoin here than the
stock market but the reality is I'd
probably be selling both
when you see a recession on the horizon
is it possible that some of these asset
prices could continue to increase even
in that recessionary period so you use
Bitcoins maybe the the example
um is there a world where you know
recession comes we have to get some
easing and that drives the asset prices
up and so we're in this weird world
where like investment assets are going
up but the quote-unquote average citizen
is being hurt with a recessionary type
period
um and so it's leading to layoffs and
contraction and revenues of companies
and things like that or are these things
more likely to move lockstep and if we
get the recession then asset prices will
go down
great question so no uh the answer is
yes you could easily see asset markets
Rising particularly once you get into
the recessionary phase and this is
usually going back to that bear Market
study that we did with respect to the
liquidity cycle markets tend to bottom
around the inflection liquidity cycle
whether that's the beginning of the
recession or the end of the recession I
happen to think it's going to be towards
not necessarily the end of the recession
but it will be well into the recession
this time around and part of the reason
for that is twofold one we still have
structurally elevated inflation if you
look at core pce the fed's preferred
inflation metric is compounding
three-month annualized at 4.8 percent
and the reason I say compounding three
month annualized is because we know core
PC is going to go down on a
year-over-year basis and partially
mostly because the base of X are
steepening as we progress throughout the
year the issue with that is if you roll
the clock forward long enough in time
and you don't stop the compounding from
compounding at five percent eventually
you're going to bottom at five percent
and start to re-accelerate from there on
a year-view basis and that's why I'm so
concerned and I think partially I think
Jay Powell is so concerned about the
inflation Dynamics so that's one reason
why I think the fed's reaction function
to the recession will be delayed in this
particular cycle the number two reason
which is probably should have been
number one which is I think the FED is
implicitly forecasting a recession if
you look at their summary of economic
projections uh they're calling for the
unemployment rate the headline
unemployment rate to rise from 3.5
percent to 4.5 percent by the end of the
year so over the next nine months
there's never been 100 basis point
increase in the unemployment rate
without a recession in the history of
the time series going back to 1940
something every time the unemployment
rate's up 150 100 basis points you are
in a recession and so you know if I can
figure this out certainly the PHD
economists at the FED can figure this
out and so I think implicitly they're
targeting for some pretty you know
meaningful impre increase in labor
market slack that I think they're not
going to be overly responsive to at the
beginning of the downturn they're going
to say Yeah we actually thought this
would happen they're not going to say oh
my God the unemployment rate surprising
we got to cut interest rates and do QE
and so that to me that's very worrisome
in the context of you know this this
broader deflation of private sector
liquidity it's like they need to be
doing something now in my opinion if
they want to ensure that we have a mild
recession and asset markets can really
survive that without you know being
scaved uh too materially I think they're
going to be way too damn late to be
honest with you and that way too damn
late is going to cause in our opinion a
lot of problems in the second half of
the year most likely concentrated in Q4
where can we send people to find you on
the internet you drop bombs on this show
every time I always learned a ton from
you where can we send people to find you
I appreciate you brother we drop bombs
on this show my friend I appreciate you
so anyway and come check us out 42
macro.com I'm on Twitter 42 macro
weather we have our private Twitter
account 42 macro is where as well so you
know we try to do our best to help the
community man I think I think there's a
lot of knowledge to be given away uh to
you know because as you know you know
this I spent my career in institutional
finance and the reality is we all need
this information it's not just the
hallowed Halls of you know Parker Avenue
and Wall Street and all the stuff that's
going to go to Boston and Congress
Avenue it's not no London and Canary
Wharf we all need this information you
know and so that's what that's what 42
macros here is to democratize you know
the world's you know world-class
institutional micro research I think
you're doing a fantastic job again I
learned something every single time we
talk so anyone hasn't checked out 42 Mac
or highly suggest you do that and we
will definitely do this again in the
future my friend appreciated thank you
man appreciate you so much love